[Applaudissements]
je vous présente notre ancêtre homo
sapiens il a les yeux grands ouverts
il regarde droit devant lui il est
ingénieux et créatifs pour faire face
aux dés il faut assurer que sa survie et
celle de son groupe
il invente des outils ils utilisent ces
outils pour faire des vêtements pour
chasser ou pour tuer des ennemis
il fait des choix
le temps passe l'humain continue à
inventer la roue
le char tiré par les cheveux les
machines et boum
nous sommes en pleine révolution
industrielle à ce moment particulier
notre histoire
les machines augmente la puissance
mécanique des humains puis la course à
l'innovation reprendre plus belle et
homo sapiens se retrouve au volant d'une
voiture il apprend à conduire en
négociant les virages en évitant les
piétons il fait des choix roulait trop
vite provoque un accident ou un autre
service en prenant au passage et
l'humain continue son évolution
l'homme invente l'ordinateur cette fois
ci les machines augmente la puissance
cognitive des humains c'est ce qui
permet aux machines de faire des tâches
qui sont en fait habituellement par les
humains on est en pleine révolution de
l'intelligence artificielle dans cette
révolution les progrès se font partout
et puis il ya de grands changements
économiques qui seront à grande vitesse
dans cette nouvelle ère de la voiture au
goût du jour ne plus besoin de pilotes
avec l'intelligence artistes
elle nous avons entre les mains un outil
puissant dont on ne connaît pas encore
toute la portée
l'intelligence artificielle votre chez
progressivement tous les secteurs de la
société
et puis il va falloir mettre des balises
pour son pour son développement pour que
ce développement soit fait de manière à
elle conforme avec nos valeurs humaines
et puis surtout qu'ils soient porteurs
de progrès social
encore une fois nous sommes face à des
choix
mais comment s'assurer de faire ses
choix de manière responsable quand
s'assurer que le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle soit fait de
manière éthique et socialement
responsable
responsable eh bien nous sommes très
chanceux à montréal parce que nous avons
des experts en éthique endroit en
politiques publiques et en intelligence
artificielle qui se sont penchés sur
cette question
et puis ils ont initié une réflexion
pour définir des principes éthiques qui
sont basés sur cette valeur fondamentale
le bien-être l'autonomie la justice la
vie privée la connaissance la démocratie
et la responsabilité c'est délibération
là ne sont ne se sont pas faites en vase
clos
elles ont pris la forme de consultation
qui se sont déroulés sur trois mois de
février à avril 2018 dans 15 lieux
publics différents et qui ont permis des
échanges avec plusieurs centaines de de
deux citoyens d'experts et des parties
prenantes de tout horizon la déclaration
de montréal est le fruit de cette
délibération dont voici les principes
le bien-être la décla la déclaration
montréal dit que le développement de
l'intelligence artificielle devrait
assurer le bien-être de tous les êtres
sensibles
est ce que je veux qu'une ya des suds
par elle-même de tuer un animal un
humain ou mettre le feu à une forêt
l'autonomie le développement de l'ia
devrait favoriser l'autonomie des
humains et contrôler de manière
responsable celle des systèmes
informatiques
alors si j'insiste aime dire qui est
capable d'analyser des radiographies et
puis de poser des diagnostics est ce que
je veux que cette ia commune et que le
diagnostic au patient ou est-ce que je
toujours qu'il y ait un médecin dans la
boucle
la justice le développement de l'ia
devrait promouvoir la justice
on sait que les systèmes intelligents
ils sont entraînés sur des données dans
lesquelles il peut y avoir des billets
est ce qu on veut qu n'y a point de
décision raciste
la vie privée à qui appartiennent mais
donner ces chenilles enceinte
est ce que je veux que la boutique de
maternité du coin m'envoie des
publicités ciblées que je n'ai pas
demandé alors le principe c'est que le
développement gliales devrait garantir
et respecter la vie privée la
connaissance le développement de l'ia
devrait favoriser l'esprit critique pour
nous protéger contre la propagande et la
manipulation
c'est ce qu'on voit avec le phénomène
des fausses nouvelles qui peuvent avoir
un impact sur la démocratie
autre cas de figure si je veux une combe
une consultation médicale sur un site
internet est plus que les communications
se font par message texte est ce que je
à voir à ce que je peux savoir si ceux
qui discutent avec moi c'est une
intelligence artificielle ou un humain
la démocratie développement de l'ia
devrait favoriser les collaborations et
le débat le débat démocratique
quand j'ai une voiture autonome qui est
devant une collision inévitable
qu'est-ce qu'elle doit protéger les
passagers de la voiture où les piétons
qui traversent sur le chemin qui vaut
faire cette décision là comment on va
faire ce choix là notre voiture autonome
faire un accident qui est responsable
alors dans la déclaration de montréal
on dit que les les joueurs les
intervenants qui développe des systèmes
intelligents devrait engager la
responsabilité de manière à gérer les
risques associés à ces technologies
si on applique bien ces princes et
éthiques
alors l'intelligence artificielle que
nous apporter beaucoup de bienfaits
on le voit ici avec les voitures
autonomes qui vont nous donner une
mobilité accrue dans le domaine médical
c'est encore plus apparent avec le
traitement des images on est capable de
détecter des cancers de manière plus
plus tôt ce qui fait que ça aura un
impact sur la survie des patients
on peut aussi travailler à faire des
médicaments ou des traitements qui tient
en compte le génome de chaque humain
donc on a de la médecine personnalisée
avec la robotique puis l'automatisation
on diminue les coûts de production et
grâce aux compressions à la
compréhension du langage naturel et la
traduction automatique
il est possible de faire des interfaces
homme machine qui sont plus accessibles
comme les assistants personnels mais
faut pas se le cacher il ya aussi des
enjeux qui viennent avec l'arrivée de
l'intelligence artificielle
ainsi ce genre en crise en jeu c'est la
publicité ciblée
parce qu'on l'a vu ça peut causer de la
manipulation et la propagande
il faut se protéger et c'est pour ça que
au canada la publicité qui est destiné
aux enfants est interdite
donc il va falloir mettre des balises à
la publicité
un autre enjeu c'est la transformation
extraordinaire du marché de l'emploi il
y à des emplois comme le disait dont on
ne connaît pas encore l'existence
ils vont être créés mais on bientôt mais
on les connaît pas en ce moment les
tâches répétitives on être automatisés
il ya des emplois qui ont une forte
composante humaine et relationnelle
comme par exemple en éducation
et puis ces emplois là ils vont avoir
une grande valeur
même chose pour les emplois qui
nécessite un large bagage de
connaissances ou des causses en
informatique
j'ai dit que les emplois en informatique
- de valoriser et puis avant 1984 les
femmes étaient présentes beaucoup plus
que maintenant en informatique
maintenant ces emplois sont occupés
majoritairement par des hommes blancs
alors comment on va favoriser la
diversité
selon la revue de business review
les deux approches qui fonctionne bien
c'est le mentorat et faire du
recrutement qui s'est précisément des
minorités et les femmes alors on voit
que tous ces enjeux qui arrive avec la
transformation du marché de l'emploi
il va falloir adressé sa en créant des
formations pour aider les gens faire ces
transitions le canada le québec
et ici à montréal on est des chefs de
file en intelligence artificielle et
nous avons fait un choix celui de prof
bout promouvoir l'utilisation
responsable de l'intelligence
artificielle
alors je vais vous donner un aperçu avec
quelques applications concrètes
d'exemples où on a fait des projets qui
vont avoir un impact positif sur les
humains le premier c'est un outil qui
aide les non voyants à détecter et
identifier des objets qui sont près de
la personne
[Musique]
ici on a un projet qui fait en
collaboration avec la croix rouge
l'objectif est de faire l'automatisation
de la notation de cartes à ce moment là
les informations terrain sont plus à
jour
quand sur des inondations à partir de
ces informations qui sont à jour on est
capable de mieux gérer les désastres que
avec les méthodes qu'on avait auparavant
voir ce qui va avoir un impact très
grand sur le bien-être et la vie de
beaucoup de personnes
un autre projet c'est de détecter les
billets de genre dans les textes parce
qu'on veut favoriser l'inclusion
l'égalité et la diversité
ici le système intelligent et c'est de
reconnaître les billets les stéréotypes
liés au genre
finalement on le voit bien comme l'art
comme par le passé
ce nouvel outil que nous avons créé nous
lance des défis
c'est un nouveau moyen de façonner de
nouveau notre monde notre futur et c'est
en notre pouvoir de s'assurer d'en
sortir du bien pour l'humanité
chacune d'entre nous nous avons un rôle
à jouer dans cette révolution c'est pas
juste la sphère des experts et puis on
peut jouer ce rôle en séduction en
prenant connaissance de la déclaration
de montréal en exerçant notre sens
critique en participant décision en
réalisant des projets qui n'avaient pas
positif pour l'humanité et puis
collectivement en mettant des balises
pour et pour encadrer l'utilisation de
l'intelligence c'est important de le
faire maintenant soyons vigilants
bienveillant et créatif
si on reste engagé à faire les bons
choix
alors nous aussi comme notre lointain
ancêtre
on peut regarder devant nous avec
assurance et optimisme gardons les yeux
ouverts
[Applaudissements]